[Music]
good morning welcome everyone welcome my
name is Siddharth hi I'm a product
manager with Google cloud security very
excited to be here today happy to see a
few familiar faces in the audience
especially excited to be talking about
Active Directory on Google cloud have
been a product manager in the industry
for about 12 years as I look back
interestingly my first conference talk
was also about Active Directory it was
at the good old directory experts
conference and if you remember that
seeing a few head nods many years ago on
a windy Chicago morning
here we are different decade different
Windy City San Francisco this time so
the weather today looks gorgeous
different cloud a cloud like no other
I'm glad I've had an opportunity to
spend about two-thirds of my career
working with large customers on
enterprise security especially delighted
to have one of the most distinguished ad
and cloud professionals in the industry
today
Kenny help from Capital One joining me a
little bit later in this session we'll
invite Kenny up to come and share
Capital One's journeys and experiences
running Active Directory on Google cloud
so let's jump in so you're at a Google
cloud conference and you choose to skip
all the kubernetes bigquery AI and ML
talks and come out to an Active
Directory presentation so I think I can
safely assume you're well versed with AD
and understand its needs in cloud
environments but if you wanted a quick
refresher Kerberos LDAP domain join
Group Policy dotnet api's these are all
good reasons why you still need Active
Directory in cloud environments and so
we will dig deeper into that today
before you go deploy your first domain
controllers in production you obviously
wanna make sure you're prepared well for
that then you look to do that on Google
cloud here's a few things you want to
think about first up you want to think
about securing your infrastructure we
have great investments in trusted OS
images she led VMs VPC service controls
so you want to think about where will
you deploy or ad domain controllers and
how will they work out second you want
to make sure only the right people can
get to the projects when you're running
your Active Directory domain controllers
so when I think about Identity and
Access Management in particular we have
other sessions that cover this in more
depth but there is a project level
permission a folder level permission and
folders it's inside of an organization
notes you want to think about I am
across all those levels and even after
you have the right I am rules in place
gonna make sure that people who are
accessing those projects are
authenticating security we're big fans
of tightened security keys and 2fa here
at Google and encourage you to think
more about those when it comes to the
actual deployment of Active Directory
you wanna think about of course a
variety of items I'm glad to share
they've been working on putting out more
solution sky it's guidance there was a
talk here last year at neck San
Francisco where we spoke about
do-it-yourself Active Directory it's
recorded and available on our YouTube
channel if you want to go check it out
but mostly I'd like you to just make a
note of these resources and dig into
those offline so we can actually cover
fresh new material today sounds good
okay so one of the things that we notice
as we work with people in the industry
is Active Directory is a very important
and a very specialized skill set I see a
couple of heads nodding and one of the
things that we tend to find is there's
people who've been great with Active
Directory working with it for dozen or
more years but they haven't had as much
experience running things on cloud
environments or their organizations
haven't empowered them the other thing
that you find is those people who are
really like up to the top notch when it
comes
- running things on cloud but oftentimes
their experience is more with cloud
native applications stateless
applications which have very different
characteristics and so when you look at
this connection you find that the set of
people who have both Active Directory
and cloud skill sets available and know
how to do it well and security is a
challenge and to help address that I'm
very excited to share that today we're
announcing managed service or Microsoft
Active Directory those of you who were
at the keynote this morning must have
heard our google cloud CEO Thomas Korean
and ions the service publicly we showed
a quick demo and if you missed it no
worries we're going to do demos in this
session most of the talk today is now
focused on how is it that you can
automate your best practices and
leverage the manage ad service for your
workloads in particular it's a highly
available service running on Google
cloud we're an actual Microsoft Active
Directory domain controllers in
production some of you in the audience I
was speaking with earlier we're saying
you're interested in learning how you
can have this work well with your
current ad so we're definitely going to
cover that in more depth as well and all
in all the idea is we'll take care of a
lot of the heavy lifting so you can be
more relaxed and focused and working on
your cloud infrastructure as I mentioned
it's actually running Microsoft Active
Directory on Windows Server it's a net
new service so we start off on the most
recent and updated bill Windows Server
2019 that Microsoft supports on the long
term servicing channel so all our beta
Active Directory domains will be running
on that OS and because it's the actual
ad you are not having to worry as much
about application compatibility or other
challenges with it you get all your
standard Active Directory features
single sign-on domain draw and through
policy and so on and most of all you can
use your familiar Active Directory
tooling remote server administration
tools and other steps to work with the
service it's a fully managed service it
runs in a highly available configuration
you can actually choose to have your
domain controllers come up in any of a
number of regions which were supporting
with the beta service takes care of
automatically patching servers making
sure we're taking snapshots and worrying
about all of those operational details
which are very important but somewhat
repetitive and we make sure we keep that
up in a good and healthy state so your
freedom from the mundane and can focus
and what's most important and relevant
for our organizations and it's harden
with secure configuration baselines it's
designed with security in mind which
will expand more over the coming 20
minutes or so also we're baking in the
principles of hybrid Identity Management
pretty core it is 2019 so I'm guessing a
lot of you are not starting out with
your first Active Directory your
identity as a service product we
understand that so we interoperate well
with your user identities wherever they
might recite and I'll show how in the
rest of the session as you read through
this you'll notice that we're also
integrating well with Google Cloud DNS
and our Google cloud VPN and
interconnect solutions Active Directory
Windows Server Active Directory is
something that isn't recommended to ever
be directly exposed to the Internet so
if you have your private network from
your corporate on-premises environments
connect it up to GCP in these forms we
can actually work further with that and
as we get closer closer to GA we will
back this up with enterprise enterprise
grade essays let you take a moment to
understand what the services about and
then I'll elaborate
so the interesting thing about the
service is although it's a cloud service
working for a large set of customers
we're making sure that we bring up every
Active Directory domain for every
customer
so each customer's ad runs in a special
project on a segregated network that's
dedicated just for us you're not sharing
that with any of the other customers we
also bacon to our service the principles
of ad delegation so we have a
pre-configured admin account for you to
use and you're welcome to create
additional users and groups to use with
your Active Directory tiered
administration models as you see fit
also it works alongside with your
existing on-premises ad based on your
security posture and needs we support
both one-way and two-way forest level
trust with your existing Active
Directory domains one or more domains so
whatever works well for you what the
service is really doing is going ahead
and automating a bunch of different best
practices which you otherwise have to
worry about and manage on your own into
the nature of our design for instance
when domain controllers come up they
come up one in each zone so it's highly
available in whichever region you
specify we're running a bunch of
Diagnostics regularly every few minutes
and making sure that the Active
Directory domain health is getting
populated and reported back we're
backing up your Active Directory domain
data every single day so that we could
recover in the instance of any issues
we're addressing the iam challenges we
mentioned earlier and the operational
challenges by having engineers for Bill
skilled in both Active Directory and
Google cloud as we build out the service
and the security aspect is so Coralie
engrained into the service that if you
just ask us to make an ad domain
available we don't just go ahead and
make it available on any of your
networks you authorize specific VPC
networks and the ad domain is accessible
only from those so if you want to
segregate your environments you can
definitely do that building out and talk
more about the security aspects of the
service we're automating our firewall
rules and one of the challenges that
happens when you self deploy is you may
have the right firewall rules in place
on day one
but somebody else came in after the fact
and changed the firewall rules because
they were deploying a web server and
before you know it you have sensitive
data coming onto the same network so
because it runs in an isolated Network
and we automate and enforce the firewall
rules were able to address this very
well as you are aware Windows Server
releases typically monthly security
patches so we go ahead and patch your
domain controllers now when you're
updating edie you need to make sure that
you're doing it systematically so the ad
domain remains available while the OS is
being updated so we go ahead and take
care of all of that orchestration on
your behalf the service level API
operations are integrated with cloud
audit logging so if somebody came in and
reset the admin account password through
our service API you would definitely be
able to see that in cloud audit logging
from the get-go the last two points are
pretty interesting and key to
understanding how the service works with
security any time our service code needs
access to sensitive Active Directory
credentials we're taking the utmost care
to make sure that we are protecting them
in a safe manner we actually have a key
for Active Directory domain for Active
Directory managed domain held in cloud
kms and this key is what is utilized to
go ahead and make sure that your secrets
are encrypted and your 80 domain
specific credentials are getting rotated
every 30 days we also enforce safeguards
for preventing elevation to domain admin
in particular a lot of our service level
code is actually been through and
released after it passes peer reviews
and our internal security reviews in the
event that a human needs to go in and
access the manage or manage the domain
in the event of an incident we actually
have a whole internal process in place
they need to be on call they need to be
in the right probes and they get that
elevated access for only very short
amounts of time that may be needed to
address the issue and then it goes back
to being fully automated from there on
so I've been talking about the service
for a few minutes probably interested in
taking a look under the hood so let's
jump
so we have the UI for the managed
service as you can see I have pre
created to manage ad domains here for
you
corporate and partners if you go in and
dig a little deeper you see that it is
running the domain controllers are
deployed in uswest one the active
directory is working just fine
let's jump in you'll see a few more
details come up about the service in
particular I wanted to focus your
attention on the networks so you can see
do I have other networks in this project
it's only available on the authorized
network this one and there's a few more
aspects about the service you can read
through now I wanted to pause here and
ask you how are you guys doing all good
head nods and thumbs up one time now if
you think about what it goes into making
sure an Active Directory environment is
up and healthy is d NS a-- does it
application working is LDAP working
Kerberos working are people able to
connect to it are the right signals
being sent I could go on it's tens of
items that are checked on each and every
domain controller and aggregated back up
to give you that simple thumbs-up and
that's what's going into that health
monitoring signal so we're taking care
of that complexity so you can just focus
on the service being available and be
productive with it and we've actually
integrated this signal with stock driver
so as I go ahead and dig in you'll see
our start our UI come up in a second
and what you're noticing is that the
moment it comes up you're able to get a
simple graph of how the service has been
performing so you can see as we expect
there were no issues with the service
Sall good using the stackdriver UI
capabilities you can very quickly go and
take a look how did it perform over six
hours over the last day over the last
week and you can notice this manage ad
domain has been behaving perfectly fine
you can actually get at a glance view of
not just this domain but all your
managed Active Directory domains so if I
drop the filter on the fqdn you'll see
both the rows come up so both the
corporate and the partner's domain have
been behaving well over the entire week
so this saves you time in being able to
get a quick at a glance view and if you
ever needed to go back in
investigate things you can see how it
performed historically what we have done
with the service is really distilled
down all the items that go into creating
it - a few simple steps how many of you
remember dcpromo yes you've seen how
it's evolved over the years from it
being a very specific bunch of inputs
that need to be given to somewhat more
simplified but still multiple step
process in the add rules wizard for
Windows Server and what we do is we go
ahead and take all of that complexity
down to what's the absolute minimum set
of things we need from you and I have
two pre created I'll try and zoom into
it all we need is the name of your
Active Directory domain the network you
wanted to be authorized on so it could
be default you could select others in
the project the IP ranges we should use
and which region would you like to bring
up the domain controllers and another
interesting thing I should call out is
in GCP our VPC networks are multi region
aware so if I make it available on the
default Network and the default Network
has subnets from five six ten different
regions then your infrastructure running
in all of those regions can still access
this manage ad domain even when the
domain controllers are being deployed in
u.s. West Chu so something to think
about as you design your infrastructure
on DCB so this is a service level view I
also wanted to hit one more point which
is you can utilize your standard active
directory tooling to manage this active
directory managed service so let's jump
over i'm already already peed in to a
windows vm now this VM is domain join to
the GCP manage Active Directory domain
you can see I'm logged in by a user
account that sits inside the corporate
domain I showed you a couple of minutes
ago you can now see that I'm looking at
the service through the Active Directory
users and computers UI which I'm
guessing a lot of you are probably
familiar with the same VM we are now RDP
into as expected has a computer account
in the Active Directory domain so you
could use ad you see to do other items
those of you who are using the newer
tool which is the active directory
administrative center that works well
with
- you can see that I've organized my
users and drops into - oh use one for
finance the other for marketing and
insert of Finance I have a few users I
have a couple of groups pre-created and
so on also Active Directory operations
are scripted a lot of the time so this
also works with Active Directory
PowerShell this is the standard get ad
group member Active Directory PowerShell
come on and as I go ahead and run it you
will see that it will show two of those
users are part of that group so
whichever may be the standard ad tool
that you are used to utilizing you can
actually use that on an infrastructure
reom that you control to connect up to
this manage ad service so that's the
service that's been under the hood let's
come back to the slides and I'm
especially excited to invite on stage
Kenny Hill from Capital One who will
come and share Capital One's experiences
running Active Directory on GC p welcome
kenny excited to have you here hi guys
I'm Kenny Hill from Capital One
I'm in Identity and Access Management
space my main focuses directories with
an emphasis on the cloud I think you
said
a capital one we are still very
dependent on Active Directory as I many
imagine many of you are here today many
of you have probably gone through
mergers acquisitions maybe a handful of
domain migrations your directories are
possibly fairly complex you have a
laundry list of applications that are
dependent on Active Directory fast
forward a bit to taking your directory
into the cloud where you have a whole
new level of capacity management the new
type of monitoring and really does the
same security model that you had
on-premise hold true to being in the
cloud we currently domain join all
windows in most of our Linux - Active
Directory during the boot process so
this is built into our image where
before the any instance is even
available its domaine join doing this
allows us to apply default domain policy
x' fully control who's able to
authenticate including local
administrative rights in just many
commercial off-the-shelf products are
just dependent on Active Directory
examples are anything with like I is
integration or sequel dependencies when
we first got started we domain joined
our instances to our on-premise
directory this worked it was also not
the most popular due to the number of
firewall ports we had to open so think
about opening every project application
project I don't know how many of you go
on to a network review and said I need
some ad ports okay well no I don't want
all of them I only need like 44,000 of
the 64,000 it's oh we also experienced a
little bit of latency on our domain
joins with this and a little bit slower
logon problem policy processing time one
thing to point out in this model is it
also kind of pins you to a single point
of failure with your network
so if you were to lose your network
connectivity you are not really taking
full advantage of built-in Active
Directory
resiliency so AD
next-closest site gives you a little bit
more with DC locator where it can find
where you want it to go next
that's actually really interesting and I
wanted to reflect on that because
sometimes when customers start out you
first think about just connecting up
your networks through our hybrid
networking solution but as Kenny's team
started experimenting with it you notice
that it was leading to a higher latency
and silent right upon you can you share
with us what did you do next to lower
that latency down sure said we knew that
you utilize going back Tom premise
presented too much a risk if we were
going to require everyone to domaine
join and we lost network then
applications couldn't scale and that's
part of going to the cloud you want you
want to be able to scale up and down so
we decided to expand our enterprise
directory to run on GCP compute
instances essentially we're treating our
we're treating GCP as you know
infrastructure as a service for our
Active Directory this model worked and
it gives us more resiliency that our
business required its in order to make
AD truly resilient though in this model
you may not achieve the cost savings
that you're being asked to to get to
with moving to the cloud you're going to
have to run a large number of domain
controllers you're going to run in
multiple zones gonna run in multiple
regions where you are you you also are
going to take on a whole new level and I
am instead of capacity management
there's a new type of monitoring and
there's a lot of automation built into
building out the main controllers
monitoring site reliability
to keep domain controllers running as
infrastructure-as-a-service
one of the challenges for us was
staffing so you active directory's been
around 20 years I don't know how many of
you been utilizing for 20 years to take
a traditional team of Active Directory
subject matter experts and have them
also still remain really good at keeping
Active Directory running and secure but
also learn new C ICD sake reliability
and other DevOps strategies is a bit of
a challenge there's a large potential
gain in in this model but it's something
you want to weigh again against the
additional overhead in challenges right
so the interesting thing from these
experiences is you saw Capital One
deploy self managed Active Directory in
production which is definitely a
supported choice and our similar to our
last year we went into detail how you
can set that up in best practices
however oftentimes as you look to do
that you end up realizing that there is
more operational overhead your teams are
having to take on what we hear from
Kenny is how is it that Capital One
looked to reduce that operational
overhead by utilizing Google solutions
okay pretty sure these are probably SIDS
favorite slides how manage directories
in the cloud is the direction Capital
One is trying to go we we have not quite
figured out what sits in the central as
our central repository for
authentication in authorization what we
do know though is we are gonna still
have Active Directory dependent
applications for any foreseeable future
utilizing managed ad as a
software-as-a-service model allows us to
reduce our normal day-to-day domain
admin directory in infrastructure tasks
and focus more on additional identity
access management components in the
cloud
removing the computer traffic to our
directly to our enterprise directory
also allowed us to reduce some of the
number of domain controllers that were
deploying in the cloud it also adds a
little a few security benefits that will
we'll go into in a bit
makes sense and so what you hear from
Capital One is how they then started
using the GCP managed ad domain however
this is a standalone to mean in its own
forest so Kenny can you share how you
connected this with your existing Active
Directory in topology sure what we did
is you you can see is it's a huge
requirement for us to continue to manage
in our own identities so we are multi
cloud and we want to treat our
enterprise directory kind of as a hub
the for for really any service we're
going to use you can see in this model
we are creating a one-way forest trust
from managed ad to our enterprise
directory that this allows us to
continue to utilize our corporate
credentials for authentication or ad
groups that we have built into our
provisioning system for authorization we
already had domain controllers running
in GC P so we kept those in place and we
just reduced the number the number that
we had deployed in this this gives us
more or less dependency on the network
going back to on-premise so almost
everything in Active Directory will work
with an isolated domain controller there
are a couple things that won't work like
password reset but hopefully you're not
using a cloud cloud for password resets
like that we domain join compute
instance to manage Devi then all user
authentication traffic or authorization
with your ad groups is
is going to go from the manage ad to
enterprise directory Wow all computer
authentication traffic is going to go to
and even GPOs stuff is going to go to
the managed ad interesting so we can see
now how Capital One was able to use the
manage ad domain with the trust
relationship that their existing
on-premises ad and get operations to
work what's especially exciting is Kenny
if you can share how this actually held
an answer cloud security overall
definitely so I'm gonna go over a couple
of the security benefits this slide is
kind of busy
the you guys in the room may not be
scared to put your infrastructure into a
public cloud but I guarantee you there
there are a few naysayers there are few
people who in your company who who are
scared and it's really fair right the
the number of breaches we read about on
almost a weekly basis and Active
Directory is oftentimes maybe not called
out in the news article but in the post
follow up of how the breach occurred
Active Directory was one of the things
that was compromised so a in this model
the top the top diagram you can see that
a computer directly domain joined to the
corporate forest you may not be aware
about a computer can authenticate the
same as a user if you're familiar with
the Active Directory schema really a
computer is a member of the user object
class Oh in this in the top diagram a
computer domain joined has the
capability running a system if you were
to lose that that instance to query your
ad data and know you should you most
likely not gonna have sensitive data in
your directory though it's not really a
good idea that to really give somebody a
path on how to all of your user accounts
all your
computer names in the bottom model
utilizing a resource forest model the
the computer has no ability to query the
directory without additional credentials
this next slide is a little bit more
about monitoring Active Directory is
super chatty
so logs often roll in in when you're
running in the cloud and you you have a
large number of instances spinning up or
scaling if you're not really careful it
is easy for to hit Windows Event log
limits per second where you you you
aren't getting the logs and I'm not sure
if any of you seen that but there's
times that things are occurring and
they're not going into the about logs
because you're you're going over your
limits so in the bottom model removing
the computer authentication GPO
processing and all of that you're really
just you're able to focus on your user
authentication and this so this allows
you to be a little bit more precise and
look for promiscuous activity you can
still monitor the traffic to the managed
ad it's just not as critical as
monitoring the user authentication --hz
many of you may be familiar with
selective authentication if not setting
up selective authentication on the trust
allows you to determine really choose
who's going to authenticate across the
trust when your fully mature in the
cloud really you shouldn't have users
logging in with that said that is a very
long transformation and there will
always be exceptions so you should only
need to have service or system accounts
whichever one term you use that are that
are authenticating on your systems and
then maybe a small subset of privileged
users who are allowed to
to directly login to an instance in the
cloud if there is a sub incident or
something you can so with that smaller
set of credentials that you're allowing
you can then apply a more complex
password set and you can rotate the
passwords more frequently you can deny
most regular users from ever logging
into anything and say if you're running
Citrix or something like that you can
build out a a oh you in managed ad that
has allowed to authenticate on it and
those users could log into Citrix
instances but they would never be able
to log into anything else in the court
model above at the top what I'm showing
is this is completely dependent on a
local resource access control list and
anyone with administrator rights can add
more so maybe they want to add their
co-worker because they think they need
access in the bottom model with the
Selective authentication you're really
you're adding another layer so you're
you have the local access control list
but then you also have another layer
that you can tie into your provisioning
system and you're controlling who's
gonna ever be able to go across the
truck lost trust so essentially you're
doubling your access checks to recap
utilizing GCP managed ad as a resource
Forest allows us to maintain the
resiliency in our business requires
reduces our operational overhead and
continue to utilize our internal
directories for authentication and
authorization while also adding a few
additional security elements to us so
we're looking forward to consuming in
general availability and Sid I want to
thank you and your whole team for
allowing us to
part in the Alpha in inviting us back in
everybody thank you very much and feel
free to connect afterwards I love
questions
oh thanks it thank you so much Kenny so
to recap area that you've heard about
our service you've heard how Capital One
has been using it and connecting it with
their existing domains and what I wanted
to do in the next segment is speed
through a few specific uses of the
service so as you're mulling about well
how do I use this thing which use cases
are interesting and I'm gonna go through
five DCP use case very quickly to help
spark some ideas so let's jump in first
up what's probably the first thing that
you do with Active Directory when you're
bringing up an infrastructure you go
ahead and domain join it and so we have
made investments to make that domain
join process be easier how so remember
how when we created an Active Directory
domain you asked for it to be available
on an authorized network and by the way
you can come back and update those
networks later as your needs change no
problems what we do is we actually
create a private managed DNS zone in
each of those networks so that when you
then bring up a VM it can just discover
the manage ET domain without you having
to do any kind of complicated per VM
configuration so that's how domain join
works you also saw Capital One talked
about how they are actually solving
another interesting identity requirement
I hear often from our customers which is
I want my user identity to still
originate on-premises and so what you
can do is you can have your VM be domain
join to GCP managed Active Directory
domain while your users can silverside
on-premises let's jump in and take a
look at this in a demo in the interest
of time I pre-recorded the video and I'm
just going to talk through it as it
comes up great so what you'll see as we
go ahead and hit start on the video is
when this starts playing can we do that
from the back of the room please great
thank you
so as this comes up you will see that I
have already created a managed Active
Directory domain and that managed ACTU
directory domain is atmo calm so we have
the domain controller supplied in u.s.
central one and it's in a healthy state
as I jump in you can actually see that I
have pre-configured this managed Active
Directory domain with a one-way forest
level trust going back to your
on-premises ad domain which is on from
ad dot demo so that's the name of my
on-premises domain
I'm now going to go ahead and switch out
into an application so you're actually
seeing sharepoint run in a VM on GCE and
the user identity which we have used to
access it just now was actually a user
account the user account the star in
your on-premises ad domain so this is
how you can go ahead and actually have
your Active Directory domain the manage
one help your infrastructure while your
identities originate on-premises let's
come back to the slides and dive into
the next use case and so as that comes
up the thing that you think about doing
after domain join is group policy so
we're going to go ahead and see how we
can have group policy be working well
with the GCP manage ad domain what you
can see here is inside of the GCP
managed Active Directory domain I have
an oh you and as your computer accounts
come up and domain join the GCP manage
ad domain you have those computer
accounts coming up in that
organizational unit v can actually go
ahead and create a GPO that links
directly to that or you and what this
enables for you is your computer
accounts your service accounts related
group policy all of that is processed
entirely in the cloud without having to
go back to on premises improving
performance and latency for you next use
case number three we actually have an
interesting feature in DCP called as OS
logon have some of you heard about it a
few one of the things that we hear about
on OS logon is it works great for Linux
how can I get something similar for
Windows
so using GCP managed Active Directory
domain what you can do is you can
actually have the same group policy
processing mechanism we utilize to let
you be able to control RDP access onto
your own onto your VMs in particular we
actually pre-cleared for you a RDP
admins group and you can just add and
remove people from that crop and that
sort of users are the only ones will
then be able to RDP to those Windows VMs
I do want to call out that while the
service can enable this all the things
we spoke about I am because this is no
your infrastructure do apply so you
still want to think about who has
computing since admin set I am policy
and other permissions on those GCP
projects while you utilize the service
but this is a use case we also enable so
far we've been covering a lot of
traditional enterprise use cases so
let's mix things up a bit
I'm now going to talk about manage and
send scripts now this is actually an
interesting feature the GCP already
supports that allows you to treat a
large collection of VMs as a single
entity to control and manage one of the
interesting things that we have done is
we have a script and a solutions guide
which we intend to publish with the beta
of the service which actually allows you
to have these VMs coming up in the
manage instance group and be
automatically joined to the GCP managed
ad domain now what this does is it
therefore allows you to utilize manage
instance groups in interesting ways
for instance is servers tend to be an
interesting web service web server that
a lot of you still potentially use and
ice web servers and other website
contents are good target use cases for
managing send scripts let's go one step
further and actually cover a fifth use
case which is how can this manage ad
service actually help modernize your
applications so for that we're going to
go ahead and switch to a demo and I'll
talk you through it as the demo starts
one of the interesting things to notice
is we are starting off an on-premises so
these are this is an app and it's
backing database running in an
on-premises VM is actually a Linux based
VM this time that we're looking at I go
ahead and I have this ad you see from
on-premises connected up to the GCP
managed Active Directory domain as you
can see that is a user chain we have pre
created in that ad domain I'm now
logging in using genes identity into
suite CRM app which is so far and still
running on premises as this load
Jane can get to all of her data and go
about her work will not do something
interesting you heard us talk about
anthos migrate also known as well as our
our v2k technology yesterday the command
that I just ran in the bottom of the
screen actually went ahead and took
those VMs and modernized them as I hit
refresh and this comes up you will see
that those applications are rack now
running in a stateful set on gke I dig
in and I'm gonna go ahead and make a
note of the IP address this is where the
application is running now so you just
saw us take that VM running on-premises
now running in a container using our
other GCP offerings while still
utilizing the GCP manage ad service the
way that fits into the picture is we're
now gonna go ahead and login to that app
now running in a container using the
same user account we logged in with
while it was still on thermoses and so
as we go ahead and hit login you'll see
this complete chain can access her data
and this is how while we do focus and
empower traditional applications you
have a good example of utilizing the
manage ad service to even help you
modernize your applications so these are
the few specific use cases specific to
GCP as we come back to the slides i
wanted to go ahead and build upon these
with two more very interesting examples
i'm glad we have exciting industry
partnerships with other technology
partners and in particular i'm excited
to talk to you about what we have done
with i topia the adobe our team is
actually in the room today i'm excited
to announce that before we launch our
beta they have pre integrated with the
GCP managed active directory service in
particular what's interesting is a year
or so ago the i topia team built out
automation on GCP where as a part of
bringing up their automation they needed
Active Directory deployed so they were
bringing up the ad domain themselves and
managing around on their own with the
GCP managed ad service that actually
able to offload the creation and
management of that ad domain over to us
by
adding an integration into their UI you
see a screenshot come up in a second and
you can see the third option for GCP
manage Active Directory domain is
integrated with the i2p offerings I'm
also excited to share that we have
worked with Citrix Citrix is of course a
company which a lot of you are familiar
with and likely using their products in
a variety of ways like many enterprise
applications Citrix also requires Active
Directory for authentication sign into
apps and desktops that run on GCP the
interesting thing that I wanted to touch
upon about the Citrix integration is
when we work with them they work with us
and some other managed services on GCP
and they were able to really reduce the
amount of infrastructure but somebody
needs to run and self manage from seven
instances down to two by utilizing more
than the platform offers something to
think about as you plan out your own
deployments and infrastructure
automation so to summarize what we have
covered so far they're excited to share
with you today we have a managed service
for Microsoft Active Directory it helps
you solve concrete GCP use cases suppose
production apps running on Linux and
Windows helps you in your app
modernization journey reduces overhead
helps you automate best practices and
enhance your cloud security footprint
the service will be coming up to you in
later this year it will be in beta and
in particular I want to highlight these
two links we're not gonna be charging
for the beta it will be free to test
you'll still have to pay for your own
infrastructure and the second link in
particular is exciting because that's
where we're happy to share we're
launching a pre signup form so if any of
this looks interesting to you and you'd
like to try the service out please go do
G that's G dot CEO slash managed MSFT ad
and fill out the interest list form we'd
be happy to get back in touch with you
and the services available
[Music]